wenn etwas uns fort genommen wird womit
wir tief und wunderbar zusammenhängen so
ist viel von uns selbst mit ford
genommen
mit diesen worten beschrieb der dichter
rainer maria rilke 1 den grund
menschlichen zustand über den wir heute
gemeinsam sprechen und nachdenken wollen
den zustand der trauer und ich bin sehr
froh dies mit zwei menschen tun zu
können die neben vielen anderen dingen
unseres lebens auch über die trauer und
das trauern intensiv nachgedacht haben
und geschrieben
die psychologin verena kast und den
philosophen will im schnitt herzlich
willkommen herr schmidt sie sind ein
vielleicht sogar der philosoph der
lebenskunst und bei der lebenskunst geht
es darum im eigenen leben sehen halt
festigkeit zu geben auch in
krisensituationen wie es denn dass bei
ihnen persönlich gewesenen trauerfällen
hat ihre eigene philosophie ihn da
helfen können erst mal nicht aber ich
glaube dass es nicht ehrenrührig
im ersten moment wenn ein trauer erfasst
dass es dann wenn etwas vom eigenen
selbst vom eigenen leben verloren wird
das zeigte er wie eng man mit etwas oder
jemandem verbunden war
dann ist erst mal nur kann es war sein
also der zweifel daran der der
verzweifelte versuch die wirklichkeit
nicht für voll zu nehmen und dann
ja wie soll ich sein total verzweifelt
zu sein
da hilft alle philosophie nichts erstmal
ist völliger verzweiflung und erst dann
wenn das sich erschöpft hat dann setzt
das denken wir da ein und dann hilft
philosophie ist dass in der psychologie
und der psychotherapie fast in ihrem
eigenen fall auch hatten sie auch diese
in wirklichkeit dieser sprachlosigkeit
ja ich glaube das hat man immer die
frage das erleben von verlust und wie
kann ich umgehen mit verlust das sind
natürlich zwei dinge und ich habe ja mal
ein buch geschrieben nur als zu der zeit
das ist ja ein sehr altes buch zu der
zeit war eigentlich hat man trauern
überhaupt nicht verstanden
es war einfach so dass man sagt naja
also man muss tapfer sein
das muss man durchstehen das stimmt
alles oder man muss es durchstehen es
ist auch eine große herausforderung aber
ich selber hab dann bei mir gemerkt dass
ich ganz eindrückliche träume hatte die
mir geholfen haben mit der trauer
umzugehen und das war dann der anfang
meines nachdenkens über das trauern
und wenn ich jetzt jemanden verliere ich
hoffe das kommt nicht so schnell vor
dann ich weiß wie es ist ich weiß wie es
tut
ich weiß wie diese emotionale
erschütterung dass es einem den boden
wegnimmt
ich weiß aber auch es ist ein langer
prozess ist ein lebendiger schmerzhafter
prozess
und da komme ich auch wieder so ins
leben hinein dass ich das leben auch
wieder wirklich gern haben kann von
psychologen und therapeuten erwartet man
ja oft rezepte manchmal sogar
patentrezepte gibt es die denn im fall
des grauens
also patentrezepte in dem sinn gibt es
natürlich nicht aber es gibt schon
also es ist ja eine situation ist ein
prozess und trauern ist ja ein prozess
ganz emotional ist oder deshalb haben
wir ja das trauern zuerst auch einfach
nur im körper also unsere emotionen sind
dein körper das ist etwas was wir
biologisch mitgebracht haben und der
körper fühlt sich ja dann auch ganz
furchtbaren und da könne man so langsam
uns sagen wir auch so das ist weil ich
jemanden verloren habe aber wie geht man
mit solchen emotionen um oder auch
später bei trauern wie mache ich die
erinnerungsarbeit ich denke da haben wir
ganz klare möglichkeiten den menschen
hilfestellung hilfestellungen zu geben
und das ganze zu errichten
sie sprachen davon dass hat mich jetzt
fast ein bisschen gewundert dass wir
sagen wir haben über das trauern gar
nicht nachgedacht wir müssen das trauern
erst wieder neu lernen in der
philosophie gibt es ja eine lange
trauern lehre die bis auf die antike
auch zurückgeht gibt es denn da
haltepunkte uns dinge die man sagen das
gilt für jedes individuum das trauert
das gilt es zu beherzigen
nicht dass ich wüsste dass die
philosophie sich übermäßig mit dem
trauern befasst hätte das ist vermutlich
auch ein grund dafür dass ich selber mir
einiges erst aneignen musste und lernen
musste mir war sehr hilfreich eine
arbeit durch 14 jahre hinweg nebenher
am spital affoltern am albis hier in der
schweiz gemacht habe
denn natürlich hatte ich da mit vielen
menschen zu tun die etwas oder jemanden
verloren haben etwas nämlich ihr
gewohntes leben verloren oder jemanden
verloren oder selber das leben verlieren
würden
und da ging es sehr stark um die frage
von trauern
ja was hilft am meisten schweigen nicht
das habe ich gelernt sondern reden also
das was den menschen bewegt was auch
mich zu zeiten bewegt hat teilen mit
anderen mitteilen das ist ein wort das
sehr viel sagt denn das war es den
einzelnen überwältigt in diesem moment
wenn wir das anderen mitteilen dann
teilen wir das auch wenn andere ganz
sicherlich nicht eins zu eins
diese trauer haben können weil sie
selber nicht so betroffen sind
aber das bewusstsein dass andere mit mir
sind das anderem ihr beistehen das
andere an mich denken dass andere mit
mir fühlen mitgefühl haben hilft
ungemein
also ich würde herrn chance kann man das
denn machen weil sie es gibt ja eine
betäubung und vereinzelung in diesem
unmittelbaren zustand der trauer ist
dann die ansprache gleich von anfang an
etwas was sinnvoll ist oder gibt es
vielleicht noch eine ruhephase in der
man das individuum alleine lassen soll
also andere menschen sind immer wichtig
man muss sich einfach klarmachen wenn
man einen menschen verloren hat wer
reden jetzt sehr darüber dass man einen
menschen verloren hat dann sind wir ja
aus einer beziehung herausgefordert dann
haben wir eine ganz wichtige beziehung
verloren werden einsam und das in dem
menschen drumherum sehr wichtig
vielleicht in einer ersten phase da wo
man noch so das gefühl hat ich bin ja
noch ganz dumpf ich kann es noch gar
nicht nachvollziehen ist wahrscheinlich
eine warme berührung und eine warme
suppe wichtiger als das sprechen aber
menschen sprechen menschen sagen ich
musste das jetzt erzählen ich finde
einfach man muss die führung dem
trauernden lassen also
nicht das gefühl haben nicht weiß es
besser ich weiß es überhaupt nicht aber
er ist der trauernde oder die trauernde
die wenn die reden wollen reden sie aber
es geht nicht nur um regen also reden
ist natürlich unglaublich wichtig dieses
mitteilen teile miteinander aber es ist
einfach wichtig eine warme atmosphäre zu
schaffen also das gefühl zu geben
du bist nicht allein und diese präsenz
die kann auch eine körperliche seien
eine eine umarmung beispielsweise aber
sie sagten der trauen dann muss das
wissen dann muss kommen
es ist eine hohe unsicherheit in dieser
beziehung zum trauern denn manchmal das
gefühl die können gar nicht für sich
selbst entscheiden
man muss sie für uns weil sie selbst zu
taux entweder das was sie empfinden also
traumhaft ist es natürlich im zustand
des trauerns jemanden zu haben bei dem
man einfach sein kann
das können natürlich die liebsten
menschen sein das können enge freunde
seien dafür gibt's eben enge
freundschaft die noch ein bisschen was
anderes ist als sonstige freundschaft
genau dadurch zeichnet sich die die sehr
gute freundschaft aus ist ein mensch bei
dem ich sein kann der nichts fragt ihre
präsenz erst nachher einfach nur in der
tat für die atmosphäre sorgt wunderbar
ist wenn jemand ein rahmen hat einen
rahmen des gewohnten lebens in denen ich
mich jetzt nur einfügen muss da ich in
dem moment oder da der betroffene in dem
moment für sich selber kein rahmen mehr
hat keine orientierung mehr hat
paralysiert ist und erst mal ganz sicher
ist das leben geht nicht mehr weiter und
in dem zustand muss man menschen auch so
lange lassen wie er da drin ist ich habe
den zustand selber auch erlebt und wie
gesagt da hilft die philosophie
überhaupt nichts
da sitzt man und ist verloren und glaubt
an da nichts mehr
wir haben jetzt in diesen antworten
schon gehört dass das ein prozess ist
ein
es braucht zeit ist denn der zeitdruck
unter dem sich heute viele individuen
venen auch trauernde wieder
funktionsfähig zu sein das schnell zu
überwinden
aus ihrer sicht eine erleichterung oder
ein hindernis innerhalb dieses prozesses
also für mich ist es ein hindernis
also diese idee also man muss ganz
schnell wieder normal sein sonst hat man
bereits eine störung und das finde ich
das ist unmenschlich und insofern ist es
dass der druck ist hinderlich
aber man darf nicht vergessen ein aspekt
beim trauern über den werden wir
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr sprechen aber
ein ganz wichtiger ist ablenkung also
dass man nicht immer nur in diesen
emotionen drin sind sondern wir haben ja
auch als trauernde menschen haben wir
immer noch kompetenz und wir haben noch
interessen und wenn man denen nach geht
es gibt menschen die sagen einfach ich
kann meine arbeit noch sehr gut machen
solange ich da konzentriert bin merklich
ich bin auch noch der alte oder die
alles und das ist auch etwas sehr
wichtiges aber es müsste eben ein
bisschen mehr freiheit sein das müsste
mehr zeit sein aber ich verstehe sie
richtig ist kann auch ein zuviel und ein
zu intensives trauern geben in dem man
gleichsam in dieser trauer versinkt und
sich selbst als handelnde personen ganz
vergisst und nicht mehr wahr mit also
das finde ich schon also ich denke
trauern das sind ganz verschiedene
gefühle die immer einmal wieder
aufbrechen oder auch so verschiedene
plätze ich denke mal das kommt ja so
eine zeit wo man sich sehr stark
erinnert was war denn eigentlich
und das ist ja auch das wichtige amt
trauern weil wir versuchen uns ja
abzulösen und das was im leben mit
diesem menschen wichtig waren das uns
berührt hat wieder bei uns zu
integrieren
das ist ein ganzes es ist eine das ist
ein ganz wichtiger prozess und das ist
eine situation wo man dringend zeit
bräuchte herr schmidt sie haben ein buch
geschrieben über das glücklich sein aber
auch über das unglücklichsein
und dieses unglücklich sein dass das
glücklichsein ist ja eine art imperativ
unserer gesellschaft das glückliche geht
als das normale als das erstrebenswerte
ist das trauern für uns auch deswegen so
schwierig geworden weil dieser glücklich
kites imperativ über uns schwebt wir
haben mit sicherheit das ist auch der
grund warum mir das unglücklichsein
schon am herzen lag bevor es mich selber
auch mal stark erreicht hat die einsicht
das leben nicht nur aus glück besteht
ist heute eine demo mit mühe an menschen
heran getragen werden kann
wir leben in einer zeit in der eine
reihe von leuten ihr geld damit
verdienen anderen leuten weiszumachen
dass das leben nur aus club besteht
und leider sind viele menschen so eng in
den arbeitsprozess eingebunden dass sie
das auch einfach glauben mal selber ein
bisschen drüber nachzudenken kann das
denn sein
und wie kommt das denn das obwohl ich
alles versuchen mit diesen
glücksratgeber nicht pausenlos glücklich
bin
der normale menschenverstand möchte ich
meinen würde dann doch den gedanken nahe
legen hat das vielleicht was mit dem
leben zu tun
das leben nun mal nicht allein glücklich
macht kein einziges leben möglich sein
ist teil des ich glaube im moment
verwechselt man lebendig sein mit
glücklichsein ja also von dieser idee
her oder alles muss glücklich sein usw
also dass ein unheimlicher druck drauf
aber ich finde es ist irgendwas falsch
ist weil es fällt ihr keine menschen ein
dass man immer nur glücklich sein kann
nicht also muss es ja irgendetwas
anderes sein und ich ist mir jetzt gut
gefallen dass ich gedacht habe
lebendig sein ist ja wehren sich ein
hoher wert vielleicht so lange ihr leben
lebendig zu sein da das das ist ja auch
sehr interessant weil die trauer mit
einem zustand verbunden
es bedient das lebendig sein er löst ein
mensch ist nicht mehr endgültig nicht
mehr lebendig aber der trauernde ist
enorm lebendig also diese emotionale
prozess des trauerns ist ein prozess der
sehr weh tut und was wehtut ist lebendig
das ist ja auch der unterschied zur
depression
aber da ist das ist nicht so wie dieser
gegen st
so da ist etwas zu ende tod und der
andere ist noch da ist noch leben wenn
es um gar wehtut
es ist nicht nur beim ende an dass
menschen so seien auch beim ende eines
einer lebensphase ja klar ist dieses
leben wirst du nicht mehr leben ja und
es ist jetzt er sich auch trauer nennen
kein gedanke mehr an
da könnte vielleicht noch ein anderes
leben möglich sein nein erstmal ist nur
vorherrschend dieses leben wie ich
gelebt habe ist nicht mehr möglich
irreversibel daran kannst du gar nichts
ändern was für modernen menschen der an
selbstbestimmung gewöhnt ist grauenhaft
ist denn ich kann jetzt nicht darüber
bestimmen dass das leben wie ich gelebt
habe und geliebt habe aber hier zu
bleiben hat es ist nicht mehr hier und
ich kann es nicht ändern möchte schon
annehmen dass das menschen in früheren
jahrhunderten nicht dermaßen getroffen
hat weil geht daran gewöhnt waren dass
sie sowieso überhaupt nichts zu
bestimmen haben ja die haben noch ein
schicksal glaubt nicht die haben an
schicksal glaubt und für den modernen
menschen ist klar es gibt kein schicksal
und es gibt aber doch schicksal wir
wissen nicht woher geschickt aber
schicksal definiert als etwas was wenn
es kommt aufgrund eines unglücks auf
grund einer krankheit oft und was auch
immer
würdest du das leben so nicht mehr
weiterleben das genommen alles schicksal
darf ich versuchen das begriffliche
vielleicht so zusammenzufassen es gibt
die unverfügbarkeit in unserem leben die
hereinbricht dinge über die wir keine
macht haben das nennen wir oft schicksal
und dann gibt es endgültigkeit im sinne
von ihrer versierte würden sie das so
fassen wollen das trauern immer dann am
platze ist wenn endgültigkeit ins
bewusstsein tritt ja während klar und
zwar im negativen sind es gibt ja
vielleicht auch positive war sie beliebt
gutem grund das schicksal genau aber
wenn das schicksal im negativen sinne
zuschlägt dann ist das für moderne
menschen mehr als hart und vermutlich
auch aus dem grund brauchen wir gut ein
gutes teile psychotherapie
weil wir wer sollen menschen ansonsten
auch bei spielen in früheren zeiten sind
dann in so einem fall theologen den
menschen beigestanden
die erklären konnten dass das ganze eben
von gott geschickt worden ist und dass
das schon ein plan dahinter stecken
würde daran glauben nicht mehr sehr
viele menschen heute auch nicht mehr
innerhalb von von kirchen
dann bleiben sehr gute freunde und
liebste menschen mit denen man zusammen
sein darf aber wie viele menschen haben
auch das nicht
und dann bleibt in der tat nämlich
jedenfalls anja die therapeutin
was müssen dann noch fasziniert und auch
ein bisschen fraglich werden das ist ja
dass menschen von uns gehen dass wir
sterblich sind das wissen wir ja dass
sie irgendwann nicht mehr da sein wir
werden das wissen wir eigentlich auch
trotzdem kommt das wie ein skandal wie
etwas plötzlich ist wie etwas
unerwartetes wie kann das eigentlich
sein wir wissen ja alle unsere zuschauer
wir sind irgendwann nicht mehr da ja
kognitiv wissen wir es wobei der eigene
tod zu denken recht schwierig ist aber
kognitiv wissen wir dass alle leute alle
menschen sind sterblich
aber dieser moment von dieser
gnadenlosen abwesenheit den man erlebt
wenn ein mensch der mit dem man nah ist
gestorben ist dann kann man die software
kann man emotional nicht vorwegnehmen
und auch wie viel uns eigentlich die
menschliche beziehung bedeutet an
geborgenheit an hilfe oder wir denken
wir nur immer die probleme die man hat
miteinander
aber das ist ein aspekt und ein anderer
aspekt es ist ungeheuer viel
geborgenheit anregung miteinander etwas
machen angstbewältigung neue ideen
miteinander machen und darüber denken
wir in der regel gar nicht groß nach und
im moment wenn dieser mensch nicht mehr
da ist ist das alles für einen moment
einfach auch nicht mehr da diese
interessante sagt waren vom modernen
subjekt den das trauen schwer fällt das
moderne so wirkt es auch ein einzel
das und vereinzelt das denkt sich
erstmal selbst wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe und auch das buch lese ist das
trauen ein moment in dem wir begreifen
dass die einzelnen sind sondern dass die
anderen immer schon mit uns und bei uns
sind also ich gehe dann stark beim
trauern von der beziehung aus also von
der bindung nicht meint das macht auch
die moderne bindungstheorie oder wir
wissen heute dass wir schon in turin
sind bindungen darum die besser und
vertrauensvoller wir gebunden sind umso
besser fühlen wir uns in dieser welt
aber das trauern bringt uns sehr stark
zum ausdruck was für beziehungs wesen
wir sind ich möchte sogar sagen es ist
unmöglich dass allein zu bewältigen
also spätestens zu dem zeitpunkt wird
uns klar wir sind wir oder wir sind
nicht und das ist natürlich ein riesiger
schritt vom fang ich an dass wir gewöhnt
sind zum wiehern und dem punkt muss
dieser schritt gegangen werden aber der
schritt zum wir es doch erst mal ein du
wenn ich es aus meiner eigenen erfahrung
sehe ist nicht so dass ich jemanden
verloren habe sondern diese person nur
diese person das gleichsam etwas
dialogisches wird ja aber ich glaube das
ist jetzt wir sind jetzt auf zwei ebenen
wurde also dieses ich glaube du steckst
wie kann man es eigentlich verarbeiten
und dann brauchen wir die beziehung und
wir müssen das gefühl haben dass wir
eingebettet sind und sie sehen kommen
von der idee her
ich habe dieses du nicht mehr da und was
passiert jetzt eigentlich mit diesem du
und ich bin übrigens auch der ansicht
dass es eine phase der trauer wo wir
wirklich sehr stark innere ich mit
diesem du zu gange sind und außen dass
wir natürlich immer noch wundervoll ist
wenn es da ist aber aber nicht mehr so
wichtig ist und dass du soll niemals
sterben das ist da bin ich selber in
riesigem zwiespalt mehr ist theoretisch
philosophisch vollkommen klaren aus
meiner sicht dass es rot geben muss wenn
man mal durch denkt
was man heute tun sollte weil es steht
am horizont dass der tod immer weiter
hinausgeschoben wird und letzten es
vielleicht sogar ganz verschwindet aber
wenn man das mal durch denkt wird das
konsequenzen haben für unser leben die
nicht lustig sind und die harmlos ist
die konsequenz ist noch dass ein leben
das nicht mehr aufhört kein wertvolles
leben mehr sein wird aus unserer eigenen
sicht es wird lange weile ohne ende
geben also die theoretische einsicht tod
ist grundsätzlich schon sinnvoll deckt
sich überhaupt nicht mit meiner
erfahrung dass wenn das du mein liebstes
du zu verschwinden droht ich überhaupt
nicht mit dem tod leben kann und nicht
will dass es ihm geht
diese beiden dinge die eine weil die
akzeptanz so die einsicht und die
uneinsichtig gleichgewicht zu bringen
dass es das was sie sagen was ihnen und
jedem menschen offenbar sehr
schwerwiegend das ist es unerhört dass
ihr vorhin angesprochen haben
oder genau das ist so unerhört und dafür
hatten wir einfach keine modelle aber
man könnte zum beispiel sagen wenn man
von einer person weiß die ist todkrank
das geht ja heutzutage manchmal jahre
zumindest monate gibt es denn so etwas
wie ein proaktives trauern das
vergegenwärtigen eines zustandes in dem
dieser mensch nicht mehr da sein wird
ja das ist eben das spannende also in
der psychologie gibt es den ausdruck
besorgnis arbeit und diese besorgnis
arbeit ist die trauerarbeit die man
miteinander macht bevor dieser mensch
stirbt und der die ist einerseits sehr
schwierig weil menschen wird immer diese
irrige annahme haben jetzt wollen alle
dasselbe
aber es wollen nicht alle dasselbe die
einen wollen noch über die beziehung
reden die antwort sagen ach du wirst
noch nicht sterben
also da gibt es auch die friktionen und
sogar wenn man sehr ehrlich sich
aufeinander einlassen kann dieses dass
dieser mensch einfach nicht mehr da ist
das kann man nicht denken und auch nicht
völlig mit dieser begriff der besorgnis
arbeit der begriff betrifft auch die
sorge und es gibt eine lange
philosophische tradition die sagt
philosophie heißt stern werden
als ob's philosophieren nichts anderes
wäre als die besorgnis arbeit im
angesicht der eigenen endlichkeit muss
man dann schon anfangen zu trauern
selbst als mensch wenn man philosophiert
philosophieren heißt leben lernen und
ein schritt auf diesem weg ist mit dem
tod zu befassen und sterben lernen da
bin ich skeptisch die arbeit am
krankenhaus hat mich darüber belehrt
dass sterben immer unvorhergesehen
geschieht können sie sich 1000 mal
vorstellen wie sterben geht und können
auch das sehen wie sterben geht aber es
geht selten so wie ein mensch sich das
vorweg vorgestellt hat oder vielleicht
sogar vorgenommen hat insofern heißt
sorge für diesen moment des lebens der
bisher noch mit absoluter sicherheit
kommt im wesentlichen sich daran zu
gewöhnen an die gedanken dass es so ist
und verständnis dafür zu haben das ist
nun mal nicht anders sein kann aber
sorge ich möchte fast sagen die sorge
bezieht sich weniger auf das eigene
selbst auf das eigene ich sondern diese
sorge bezieht sich stärker auf den
anderen dann wenn der andere der mir
wichtig waren möglicherweise existenz
existenziell wichtig war weg es wer bin
ich dann noch das kann uns auch darüber
belehren dass wir nicht so sehr ich sind
wie wir immer glauben ich zu sein dieses
ich ist sehr sehr angewiesen auf andere
und ich für mich allein wer bin ich ohne
den anderen deswegen richtet sich die
sorge auf den anderen der andere soll
nicht sterben
ja das ist das eine aber ich denke also
jetzt ich wir nehmen's ja nicht so
philosophisch sondern wir sagen einfach
mal das ist ich bin besorgt dass das und
das passiert wir versuchen uns so gut
wie möglich auseinanderzusetzen
vielleicht eben auch schon auf einen
trauerprozess hin vielleicht auch noch
dinge die offen sind noch miteinander zu
lösen und für mich sind es dann schon
beide ich es gut dass du soll nicht
sterben aber wenn das dusch und sterbens
muss dann ist die sorge auch wie können
wir so gut wie möglich weiter leben ohne
dieses du weil man ist ja diesem du auch
noch verpflichtet wenn es gestorben ist
und es gibt auch menschen die sagen ich
würde mich eigentlich umbringen aber
dann hat ja dieser verstorbene menschen
niemanden mehr der an ihn denkt ich
finde gerade wenn solche sätze kommen da
sehen wir doch sehr genau dass man immer
noch in der beziehung denn ist doch wenn
der mensch gestorben erste impuls ist
aber dann will ich auch nicht mehr leben
naja aber dann kommt wird die erklärung
warum ich nicht mehr nötig war um mich
doch leider die das ist auch in diesem
dialogischen verhältnis die sorge dass
sterbende sagt um ich mache ich mir
keine sorgen ich mache mir sorgen um
dich als trauernde die sterben dann
machen sich sorgen um die trauernden
also ich denke man macht sich
philosophische versorgen um das du aber
also von unserer warte aus ist dieses
sich sorgen um das gilt rundherum also
und es geht immer um beziehungen wie
können menschen die auch verbunden sind
mit diesem sterbenden menschen nicht
können die damit umgehen familie die
kinder wie gehen die kinder damit um
also ich finde die sorge ist ganz weit
dieses weite feld der sorge betrifft ja
nicht nur engste freunde sondern auch
ein umfeld das dann auch verunsichert
ist und es gibt eine form der
sprachlosigkeit und es gibt rituale
diese sprachlosigkeit zu überwinden
meist beginnt es mit einer formalität
mit einer trauerkarte ich habe ihn mal
vier oder fünf mitgebracht auf der ein
steht herzliches beileid auf der steht
in stillem gedenken hier steht tief
berührt und die haben wir zwei
besinnliche motive ohne text meine frage
an sie für einen bekannten dem sie in
der trauer beistehen wollen welche karte
würden sie denn wählen weil eine offene
text jeder texte verstehen
wir haben nichts keine große aus nein
aber sie würden sich in jedem fall ohne
text scheint ja warum denn das sind doch
rituelle sprachliche formeln dient gar
nicht viel gehen klar es ist ein
unterschied wenn ich hinschauen
tief berührt mit meiner handschrift dann
bin ich wirklich gehört aber wenn das
schon vor gedruckt ist dann ist schon
mal klar ich war nicht imstande das
persönlich zu formulieren ist jeder jede
form eine floskel oder hält die formel
nicht gerade eine distanz die es zu
wahren gilt ja gut das ist ja das ist
die frage ich finde halt diese diese
ausdrücke hier
das sind so versatzstücke und ich kann
ich bin ganz einig mit mit dir man kann
ja dann drin schreiben
also ich bin ich bin wirklich tief
getroffen oder so nein es ist nicht
alles floskeln
aber es ist schwer jetzt wir wollten ja
1 wählen
ich würde dahin tendieren würde aber der
monaten drauf also ich finde das hat das
hat einen blut schnell mit wunderschön
und verblüht auch sehr schön
also von daher wäre das für mich ein
symbol von leben und tod
also jetzt nicht nur für den menschen
der gestorben ist sondern auch für die
die zurück gebete zurückgeblieben sind
und mond werde dann eben doch schon auch
wieder an frühling erinnern sommer
erinnern
ich denke das problem bei der trauer wir
hatten es vorhin mal mit auch in der
trauer nicht versinken
das heißt ja auch immer andere
ressourcen auch leben also auch im
schlimmsten trauerprozess kann ein tag
schön sein oder kann ich mich über etwas
freuen also dass die wäre denkt dass das
ist mir zu zentrieren
es ist ja auch ein symbol die brücke in
eine andere daseinsformen die sich
schließt zu einem kreis ja aber das wäre
mir jetzt so weit zu symbolistisch
ziemlich selber geht wenn es um ein
trauerfall geht dann ist das das einzige
mal dass ich keine karte verwende
überhaupt keine karte und auch keine
maschinen schafft also dass tippe ich
nicht am computer sondern das ist das
einzige mal wo ich mir einen brief
papier nehmen
und mit hand scheibe was ich zu
schreiben habe es sei denn der mensch
ist in einem anderen land und dann ist
es eine e mail die tippe ich dann eben
doch auf dem computer aber eine das
überlege ich mir jedes mal ganz neu und
das muss auch mit der handschrift getan
sein dass dieser persönliche einsatz und
auch die persönliche widmung sichtbar
wird ich will das nicht zu praktisch
machen aber das ist für viele menschen
ein problem auf trauernde zuzugehen was
hätten die dinge die man aus ihrer sicht
unbedingt vermeiden sollte also ich
meine das sind jetzt zwei dinge eine
trauerkarte schreiben und aufbauende
zugehen trauerkarte schreiben
ich finde wenn man einfach eine
erfahrung die man mit diesem menschen
gemacht hat die einem lieb ist
die einem nahe ist wenn man so etwas
schreiben kann
also ich fühle mit ihr oder so und ich
beschreibe etwas dann dieses jetzt
lehmans generell und nimmt was das ist
eigentlich was es ist nicht gut nicht
gut ist dieses ewige zögern also nicht
gut ist diese idee ist ganz falsch
machen und dann fängt man da macht man
abstand oder also ich telefoniere nicht
weil ich ganz falsch machen und ich
telefonieren nicht weil es könnte aber
eigentlich wir haben ja angst vor trauer
nicht wir denken wenn ich jetzt zu
diesem menschen hingehe und dies offen
diesem entstand so weit und ich komme
damit nicht so recht also wir wollen uns
selber schützen und ich finde einfach so
menschlich hingehen zu hören wenn der
mensch sagt du ich mag jetzt überhaupt
nicht unbeschränkt wieder gehen
aber wenn dieser mensch sagt ich will
gern mit ihr gelaufen gehen dann gehen
sie mit dem laufen auch wenn sie keine
zeit haben
also einfach dieses es braucht es
braucht eine feinfühligkeit aber ich
glaube was man wirklich falsch macht ist
dieses zögern oder auch es gibt auch
menschen die auch bei einer trauerkarte
ewig warten bis ihnen irgendetwas irgend
etwas einfällt und als der mensch finde
ich ist es schön wenn man etwas
geschrieben bekommt was einen
persönlichen einen persönlichen bezug
hat was ich mich jetzt fragen wo sie
betonen die fein
ich kite das personale es gibt nun eine
gesellschaftliche frau beides
auszuschalten um sicherheit zu gewinnen
das ritual dass es immer gleich da geht
es auch nicht um personen das gibt einen
geregelten ablauf der allen sicherheit
gibt braucht es beim tauchen dann aus
ihrer sicht gar keine rituale
doch auch nach der absolut und
glücklicherweise bietet die religion sie
nach wie vor an und so wie beim heiraten
ist auffällig dass man terror gerne dann
doch auf die rituale zurückgegriffen
wird
das hat aber auch gründe denn diese
rituale sind nicht neu
sonst wären sie ja keine rituale die
sind sehr alt und zu den dingen die
trösten können beim trauern erst mal
kann überhaupt nichts trösten das ist
dies ja zu nehmen also aber wenn die
erste phase dann zeitlich überstanden
ist wann auch immer nach tagen oder nach
wochen oder nach monaten
dann geht das sehr wohl darum was kann
trösten um dazu gehören die rituale weil
die eine andere zeit dimension haben
das relativiert dann den aktuellen fall
der jetzt geschieht aber die rituale
gekommen aus einer anderen seite sind
jahrhunderte jahrtausende alt krieg
gerät man in kontakt mit einer kultur
die weit über einen selbst hinausgeht
und gibt das dann sich direkt in kontakt
so etwas was über uns hinaus geht
denn das gibt es zweifellos sonst
könnten wir nicht hier sein und auch
nicht weg sein
es gibt etwas eine dimension aus der wir
kommen in die wir gehen und eben für
einen bestimmten zeitabschnitt hier sind
und die rituale machen uns ohne es zu
sagen klar dass dann noch eine andere
zeit dimension vor uns war und ganz
sicher eine andere zeit dimension nach
uns sein wird und wieviel das zum ersten
mal auf als meine mutter gestorben war
und ich in der kirche war wo die
trauerfeierlichkeiten stattfanden und
gebets formeln gesprochen wurden dem ich
als kind und jugendlichen gelangweilt
haben ohne ende und jetzt war ich froh
darüber
diese gebets formen zu sprechen wie eine
mühle und das berühmte mögen wie und
dann ist mir klar geworden das ist so
weil hinter diesen gebets formen steckt
eine andere zeit als es die bloße zeit
eines menschen ist
wie war das bei ihnen haben finden sie
auch oder haben sie noch in bezug zu
diesen christlichen ritualen man könnte
auch sagen sie sind erinnerungsstütze
wenn man einmal im jahr beispielsweise
einen toten sonntag feiert das sind
erinnerungs mahnungen die auch etwas
wach halten
ja also ich finde die rituale im
zusammenhang mit trauer etwas ungeheuer
wichtiges ich denke immer wenn wir
emotional sehr aufwühlende situationen
haben brauchen wir ein
gemeinschaftliches ritual und in diesem
gemeinschaftlichen ritual sind wir dann
aufgehoben können mit dieser können
können mit dieser trauer umgehen
ich finde zb das christliche
beerdigungsritualen bin der ansicht es
gibt heute neue rituale man muss auch
neue rituale schaffen die wirklich auch
zu einem sprechen
ich finde aber die elemente die das
christliche trauert beerdigungsritualen
hat ganz das ist ein kleiner
trauerprozess dann nimmt eigentlich den
trauerprozess vorweg also da ist zuerst
mal der leichen haben und dann schaut
man den noch einmal an es ist traurig
man hat musik also die emotionen sind
noch einmal angesprochen jetzt kollektiv
wir miteinander
dann ist ja meistens eine rede wo dieser
mensch noch einmal gewürdigt wird also
wird man kann schon noch wenn man sich
ein bisschen überlegen was habe ich
eigentlich mit diesem menschen erlebt
was hat dieser mensch in mir drin
geweckt und dann wird dieser leichnam in
die erde gebracht also jetzt ist es ist
wirklich ein tod es ist vorbei und dann
geht man ja meistens zu einem vesper
also man geht wieder ins leben hinein
die nahrungsaufnahme und das ist ein
ganz das ist eigentlich in kurzer zeit
ist das ist das ein trauerprozess darf
ich ihnen mal ein beispiel vorführen von
einem nicht zu rituellen sehr vielleicht
eigenwilligen trauerrituale
nämlich von conny palmen hier in der
sternstunde war und ihren ehemann
verloren hat und sich dann zu ihrem
ehemann ins bett legte und lange dort
blieb sie beschreibt das in dieser
kleinen szene
es muss ich man man man muss sich
verabschieden von so einen körper und
der ist kalt und man wird selbst sehr
kalt und es ist traurig man ist sehr
traurig war sehr traurig aber es muss
ich musste immer zurück zu diesem
körpers hatte so etwas etwas tierisches
das verlangen das und auch weil man es
nicht glauben kann man muss sich auch
gewöhnen an den tod so eines gelebten
körpers und ich bin auch froh dass wir
nicht einen menschen so schnell begraben
zb in israel wo das glaube dass oder die
wärme eines landes einen dazu zwingt
sehr schnell cia innerhalb 24 stunden
einen menschen zu begraben denn man
braucht es man braucht das diesen körper
zusehen und sich zu verabschieden
das war die niederländische
schriftstellerin conny brem zwei dinge
die mir daran sehr eindrücklich sind die
sprach von diesem tierischen das trauern
dass man sozusagen noch gar nicht als
mensch da ist sondern sich wie ein tier
an diesen anderen körper hängt und von
der von dem gefühl und der notwendigkeit
körperliche präsenz zu halten
das kann ich nicht hier durch sein wenn
wir den neurobiologen glauben dürfen
lässt sich bei tieren das bedürfnis
zutrauen jedenfalls nicht so bemerkten
wie beim menschen
das ist anscheinend an den präfrontalen
kortex gebunden das ist die reflexion
und zu dem wir fähig sind
es braucht also offenkundig die distanz
der reflexion die einem überhaupt
klarmacht was ist da geschehen und das
greift tief in sein leben ein
möglicherweise gehen tiere schneller
über zur tagesordnung und das mal so hat
zu sagen jedenfalls soweit wir das
wissen können muss man immer ganz
vorsichtig sein ja wir sind ja nicht in
den tieren drin
wir stellen uns nur von außen vor und
beobachten
insofern meint sie vermutlich mit
tierisch etwas anderes nämlich ein
verlangen nach rischen neben diesen
anderen menschen noch mal diese nähe zu
spüren und ich könnte mir vorstellen
tote menschen strahlen eine unglaubliche
ruhe aus
das kann menschen mit dem tod auch
versöhnen und ganz nah noch mal bei
diesem gestorbenen menschen zu sein der
einem sehr nahe war ist ein erlebnis
fürs ganze leben nämlich diese ruhe mit
so nennt nun in das in das kommende
leben in diesem zusammenhang ist es ja
oft eine frage die auch in meinem leben
mal sehr wichtig da will ich den toten
noch sehen will ich noch mal sehen und
auch ob kinder das sollen
wie ist denn da ihre erfahrung auch in
der therapie wie wichtig ist dass den
toten noch mal in augenschein zu nehmen
also das ist für viele menschen ganz
ganz wichtig und zwar deshalb weil wenn
wir den toten nicht gesehen haben dann
alles was wir nicht wahrgenommen haben
fühlen wir mit fantasie und da wir ja
den toten nicht weg geben wollen denken
wir ja der hat sich ja noch versteckt
er wird wieder der wird wieder
zurückkommen also den toten sehen ist
etwas meines erachtens ganz wichtig ist
sinkt mit dem alter das würden sie immer
empfehlen
ja die frage ist einfach wie man die
kinder begleitet wo es ganz
problematisch ist ist bei den menschen
die durch einen verkehrsunfall sehr sehr
verunstaltet sind ich finde auch diesen
punkt von dieser ruhe des toten oder
also ich fand jetzt das was die conny
palmen er erzählt hat tiere können
übrigens trauern sagt die effektive
neurowissenschafter bei der messung uns
ja nicht streiten aber ich denke das ist
einfach das kreatürliche oder also es
ist ganz kreatürliche ich habe diesen
menschen auch kreatürliche gelebt und
jetzt dieses erlebt
er wird kalt also kreatürlichen sie
leiblichkeit weiblich körperlich also
wirklich eigentlich unsere tier seele
und unsere tierkörper und da kommt
natürlich dazu dass der tote wirklich
sehr sehr ruhig ist also da da da kommt
eine eine ruhe
für mich ist es wichtig dass auch kinder
die die toten sehen weil der stand das
ist einfach nicht mehr der mensch wurde
also man sieht denn das ist noch eine
hülle und das ist nicht mehr der mensch
schon vorher das ist etwas anderes und
ich finde das ist wichtig für den
trauerprozess so dass auch kinder nicht
die phantasie haben und jetzt wird der
papa da in die grube hinuntergelassen
sondern dass man das ist dass es noch
eine hülle würden sie denn sagen dass
solche rituale wie waschungen das gibt
es ja auch dass kulturen den
verstorbenen die verstorbene noch mal
waschen ist dass das nach form ist der
körperlichen auseinandersetzung der bei
uns jetzt nicht mehr so stark war habe
ich weiß noch nicht ob sie noch nicht
mehr so stark ist also ich erleben fest
dass im bereich von trauern so in den
letzten jahren sehr sehr viel passiert
ist und auch im umgang nicht sterben
denn oder und also zum beispiel so dass
viele menschen bei den sterbenden sind
sie ein verstreichen
dabei sind nachher waschen oder nicht
war schon arbeiten nicht das ist
eigentlich das sind schuld das sind
schöne sind auch rituale sind sehr
schöne rituale
naja aber die todes ritualen richtig
darauf können ja sogar besonders dass
sich erstaunlich immer noch hält nämlich
wenn ein mensch gestorben ist das
fenster aufzumachen damit seine seele
hinaus fliegen kann und ich glaube auch
dass das das ist was uns trösten kann
nicht in der ersten phase erst danach
was uns trösten kann uns klar zu machen
wir sprechen zwar davon wir haben einen
menschen verloren aber wir haben ihn
nicht verloren denn das wesentliche
dieses menschen ist nicht weg das
wesentlich dieses menschen bleibt da das
war die serie lässt
ist nicht der körper denn der körper
fest ich kann gar nichts der kann sich
nicht bewegen der bewegt sich erst wenn
energie im belebt also für mich ist das
wesentliche dass ich diesen menschen in
der erinnerung bei bei mail bei mir habe
also aber nicht nur in der erinnerung
auch in seinen energien bleibt er bei
mir da werde ich jetzt schon ein
bisschen skeptisch aber wir sehen wir
nur das so sagen in diesen an diesem
punkt auch weltanschauungen intuition
sehr weit auseinander
man man man in der trauer stellt man
sich wie man zur welt an sich steht und
damit auch zum leben wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe ja ich meine aber gar
nicht weltanschaulich sondern jedenfalls
nach heutigen kriterien im krankenhaus
kann man das ja sehen auf die
intensivstation da wird was gemessen
plötzlich ist dann nichts mehr was ist
da gemessen worden elektrische energie
es gemessen worden
und die ist weg aus dem körper aber
nicht ganze kann nicht die kann nicht
den nicht zerfallen sein weil energie
kann nicht aufgelöst werden oder sich
auflösen energie bleibt bestehen und das
deckt sich mit den erfahrungen die ich
auch selber gemacht habe und die sehr
viele menschen einen berichten
der oder die ist noch da ich spüre dass
der oder die noch da ist ich glaube dass
es kein falsches gespürt das ist ein
richtiges gespür
wir brauchen nur andere welt das war für
mich ist ja die vorstellungskraft ist ja
etwas ganz ungeheuer wichtiges an uns
menschen weil in der vorstellungskraft
hatten wir eigentlich die wirklichkeit
und solange ich mir immer noch diese
menschen vorstellen kann uns vorstellen
kann was ich mit ihnen gemacht habe oder
oder was wichtig war an ihnen so lange
sind sie auch bei mir also für mich ist
trauern schon die müssen sich auch wenn
die weg bewegen dürfen die dürfen
befriedet werden
aber alles was bei mir geweckt worden
ist durch dieses leben das kann in meine
psyche integriert wird
und da muss ich auch nicht ständig daran
denken oder ich kann auch noch meter
aufs leben hinein
das ist einfach auch ein reichtum darf
ich an diesem ablösungsprozess
vielleicht anschließen obwohl das sehr
faszinierend es ist ja oft eine frage
für die trauernden für das umfeld sogar
für die krankenkassen bis wann trauern
noch normal es gibt ja die traurigkeit
es gibt das trauern und dann gibt es
dieses große feld das wir heute
depressionen nennen
gibt es denn da grenzen und wo würden
sie die ziehen die zehnmal weniger auf
das macht man weniger von der zeit
es ist ja so dass so in den ersten
wochen eigentlich alle gleich sein oder
es ist einfach furchtbar
man hat das gefühl leben geht nicht mehr
weiter ich glaube wir haben uns jetzt
schon ein paar mal eigentlich benannte
und dann gibt es bei menschen die
wirklich in einem trauerprozess sind so
ganz es gibt neue interessen gerade auch
im zusammenhang mit anderen menschen
ganz feine neue interessen für eine neue
freuden so dass man plötzlich sagt na ja
aber das könnte ja vielleicht doch
abwechselnd metall mit tagen wo es ganz
düster und dann gibt es eben die
menschen die mit einer depression
reagieren und die nicht aus ihrer
düsteren emotion heraus kommt trauernde
hatten wir ganz verschiedene
unterschiedliche emotionen oder sie
haben angst während ausgabenfreude dass
er schuldgefühle sie sind ärgerlich
und wenn man depressiv ist ist man
einfach ganz herunter gestimmt es ist
elend und es wird nie besser und die
trauernden haben auch dann das gefühl
sie haben es falsch gemacht sonst wäre
dieser mensch nicht gestorben
und das ist im grunde genommen eine form
der trauerverarbeitung gebraucht
psychotherapie also der d da ist er auch
wenn da viele menschen rundherum sind
und hilfreich sind dann das genügt
einfach nicht das ist etwas wo man dann
tiefer in sie hineinschauen muss warum
ist das jetzt eigentlich so dass ich
mich zu einer der
version reagierte also ich würde jetzt
nicht an zahlen festmachen oder also die
über das macht natürlich doch der
volksmund macht wenn sie ein jahr lang
nach einem jahr sollte es gut sein nach
einem ja es überhaupt nicht gut
in keiner weise dann fängt sie hängt ja
auch davon ab wen haben wir verloren
haben wir verloren der eine um
gewichtige rolle in unserem leben hat er
habe oder haben wir vielleicht den
uralten vater von olymp der zwar auch
wichtig war aber natürlich nicht mehr
die gleiche strecke wie wäre ein partner
oder eine partnerin also von daher wird
es nicht an der zeit festmachen
traurig sein ist normalzustand des
menschseins möchte ich sagen nicht
normal zustand den wir ständig haben
einige menschen aber schon aber ein
zustand den wir regelmäßig haben
wer im herbst nicht sich traurig fügt ja
keine wirklich vergänglichkeit der macht
was falsch in seinem leben möchte die
sache und ein spezialfall des traurig
science das ist das trauern das trauern
hat in aller regel einen konkreten
anlass
traurig sein braucht nicht unbedingt
einen konkreten anders und depression
als ganz wichtiger teil von traurig sein
kann sich während des lebens einstellen
oder kann sich wiederum aufgrund eines
trauerfalls einstellen und dann ist sehr
die frage ist es krankheit krankheit ist
es dann wenn sie den menschen nicht mehr
erreichen wenn sie mit diesen menschen
über was sprechen wollen aber dieser
mensch bleibt im zurück in seiner
gedanken was auch immer an impulsen von
außen kommt kreisen er dreht sich in
sich und wenn sie ihn nach seinen
gefühlen fragen er hat oder sie hat
keine gefühle
dann ist zwingend hoffentlich gibt es
noch das umfeld dass das erkennt
zwingend ärztliche behandlung und
therapeutische behandlung
es gibt auch jetzt schon auch von den
ärzten den krankhaften her
neue bestimmungen es gibt ein neues
manuell das sagt man nach zwei wochen
wir noch in dieser tiefen trauer ist
dann ist das schon unter pathologie
verdacht dann ist das schon krankheits
nach zwei wochen mir kommt das
unheimlich wenig vorwissen sie nach zwei
wochen merkt man noch gar nicht dass man
wirklich jemanden verloren hat am anfang
erfüllen und sich ja wie wenn man irgend
einen schlag auf den kopf bekommen hat
man funktioniert vielleicht aber aber
dieses gefühl das gefühl von trauer hat
man nicht das gute an dieser geschichte
ist dass menschen die trauern auch
krankenkassen würdig sinken das ist das
gute an der sache aber das schlechte an
der sache das furchtbar schlechte an der
sache ist dass man so gut wie wenn man
einen verlust nach zwei wochen
verarbeitet haben müsste und das ist
natürlich kann das wollen wir nicht
vergessen woher solche bestimmungen
kommen sie kommen aus amerika und die
sind für uns nicht verbindlichen auch
kulturell nicht verbindliches hat soll
heißen die kommen ausnahmen blind
optimistischen kultur optimismus ist was
schönes aber blinder optimismus ist
schwierig im leben und wir als europäer
dürfen sagen das sehen wir anders es
gibt ja auch künstlich hervorgerufenen
optimismus nämlich durch medikamente
durch stimmungsaufheller die uns die man
gerade über diese phase der taubheit
hinweghelfen
wie stehen sie zu diesem einsatz würden
sie das selbst für sich ausschließen
also war also schlief ich fühle mich
würd's absolut ausschließen
ich finde man wenn man zb sehr viel geld
einfach geht also mein geld spazierte
man geld schnell spazieren
das funktioniert mindestens so gut weil
medikament und das ist etwas ganz
interessant ist oder eigentlich will man
ja nicht mehr aber der körper geht und
dann ist da doch etwas in bewegung und
dann kriegt der körper auch wieder
hunger ich will ja nicht essen aber der
körper klickt hunger und das ist ja so
der weg dann wieder so ein bisschen der
ein bisschen ins leben hinein
das läuft hundertprozentig zu wie in weg
übersetzen ist etwas was man trauern
ungemein hilft der dran ist auch da sich
in bewegung zu setzen um dem sollen
menschen unbedingt namen geben denn es
geschieht sehr vieles dann beim
unterwegs seien zum einen der körper
kriegt jetzt ein rhythmus wieder
es ja herausgeworfenen aus allen bezügen
der rhythmus kommt wieder automatisch
kommt frische luft im körper rein gar
nichts zu unterschätzen automatisch
spielt die sinnlichkeit wieder eine
rolle wahrzunehmen welche jahreszeit
welche farben da zu sehen sind welche
welche tiere und auf die weise sie
wieder etwas ein gebunden zu fühlen in
die welt auf jeden fall also und
medikamente es gibt menschen denen hilft
das aber bloß nicht auf dauer
das ist allenfalls etwas was über ein
paar wochen hinweg helfen kann länger
sicher nicht ich mich ein bisschen
skeptisch mit dem mattie medikamenten
also ich find natürlich auch es gibt
menschen die brauchen medikamente und
die sollen die dann auch bekommen
aber das ist so ein bisschen unsere
sozialer art oder also ich habe etwas
was mir wichtig neben eine pille und
eigentlich ist der trauerprozess eine
ungeheure entwicklungsprozess der weh
tut
also ich kann wird man kann ihn meines
erachtens mit appelle nicht weg bringen
aber ich finde das sollte man auch nicht
sondern ich finde ich finde schon
menschen zu verlieren ist etwas
menschliches nicht
also wenn wir sagen wir haben keine
modelle für das traum haben wir modelle
es gibt noch ein modell das mich immer
besonders fasziniert hat ich will es das
modell goethe nennen
goethe hat nach dem verlust seines
sohnes offenbar gesagt voran
ich mache einfach weiter eine form der
trauer verweigerung fast eine idee das
trauern ein unvernünftiges gefühl ist es
niemandem hilft kann sowas auch
erfolgreich sein ich kann nur befürchten
dass das verhältnis zu seinem sohn auch
so war denn normal ist das licht
das kann nur geschehen wenn keine starke
beziehung da war
und wenn nicht
sodann anders dann war es flucht vor der
schweren herausforderungen die tauern
nun mal ist
ansonsten es braucht nicht flucht und um
etwas zu gebrauchen was in der tat sehr
hilft was tröstet nämlich arbeit aber
möglichst nicht restlos zu verdrängen
und zu fliehen vor dem geschehen sondern
nur um sich eine insel zu schaffen in
dem meer von tränen die auch unbedingt
geweint werden soll sich selbst als
handelnder überhaupt wieder wahrzunehmen
würden sie sagen oder verstehe ich das
richtig diesem meer von tränen in dem
man auch mal untergehen kann in diesem
meer von tränen eine insel zu schaffen
auf der man sich jetzt mal für ein oder
zwei stunden befindet und wenn es eine
arbeit ist an der man auch hängt dann
kann man vergessen für diese in zwei
stunden und auf diese weise wieder luft
holen um wieder zurückzukehren in das
meer dateien eine kategorie die wir bei
die wir noch nicht gesprochen haben ist
der sinn der mit dem trauer denn hier
geht es gibt ja tote die uns als
sinnvoll oder als akzeptabel erscheinen
und dann gibt es dinge wie der tod eines
kleinen kindes beispielsweise bei einem
verkehrsunfall bei denen keine sind
dimensionen erkennbar ist wie
beeinflusst das das drauf erhalten aus
ihrer sicht steht die frage nach dem
sinn ist immer eine ganz schwierige
thematik wie im traum
und also das ist vielleicht unsere
beurteilung das ist ja noch ein
sinnvoller tod also wenn ein sehr alter
mensch steht er mit 80 das ist noch
nicht sinnvollen leben also den tod
eines kindes kann man ja überhaupt nicht
verstehen nicht weil das ist die
generation die uns über die uns
überleben sollte aber ich finde ganz
grundsätzlich stellt trauerprozess die
frage nach dem sinn also diese frage
wenn man den doch einfach nur stirbt was
hat das denn eigentlich für einen sinn
und ich finde das ist eine ganz wichtige
situation als er jetzt zum beispiel in
therapeutischen prozessen das
auszuhalten
also nicht irgendeinen sinn zu geben
also ich würde auch nicht sagen
sie einen schönen trauerprozess
durchlaufen finden sie den sinn wieder
ich hoffe dass sondern für mich ist das
ganz wichtig dass man sie hat und in dem
moment habe ich jetzt das gefühl leben
hat keinen sinn der an grunde sinnlos
und das halte ich jetzt mal aus das hat
ja auch eine würde dass man aushält dass
man sagt das hat im moment das hat im
moment kann ich keinen sinn sehen und
man könnte jedem ins gesicht springen
der einem noch irgendeinen sinn erklären
will sondern das ist eigentlich dieses
ist die verweigerung und aus dieser
verweigerung heraus kommt ja dann
allenfalls etwas kreativ ist nicht
einfach ein erlebnis sollte man geht
vielleicht einem neuen interesse nach
man geht einer neuen beziehung nach und
plötzlich merkt man stellt die sinnfrage
nicht mehr aber ich finde das ein ganz
wichtiger punkt ist dass würden sich als
philosoph wahrscheinlich in gleicher
weise sagen müssen die sinnlosigkeit
gilt es auszuhalten am anfang darf man
den menschen nicht mit der frage nach
dem sinn kommen es ist klar das ist
absolut sinnlos was da geschieht
besonders natürlich in den fällen die
diese geschildert haben
aber das ändert nichts daran dass sind
menschen die frage nach dem sinn
irgendwann wieder zum vorschein kommt
und sie beschäftigt und wir haben keine
chance die frage nach dem sinn objektiv
zu klären
es kann völlig sinnlos seien
aber wir sollten auch da nicht unbedingt
mit wahrheit darauf antworten also die
wahrheit der sinnlosigkeit jetzt
konstatieren wir können es nicht wissen
was müssten wir für einen ungeheuren
überblick über haben über das leben über
die welt um von da aus objektiv zu sagen
sind los genauso wie wir objektiv nicht
zeigen können sinnvoll
das können wir nicht aber was wir können
ist ein geschehen im nachhinein sinn zu
geben also zu sagen das nehme ich zum
anlass eine stiftung zu gründen
die diese seltene krankheit erforscht es
immer das große problem bei seltenen
krankheiten
das
so wenig darüber geforscht wird und
deswegen den menschen auch wenig
geholfen werden kann oder eine
selbsthilfegruppe zu gründen
diese erfahrungen die ich jetzt
gesammelt habe einzubringen um sie
anderen menschen zur verfügung zu
stellen die in einer ähnlichen situation
sind jetzt könnte man sagen das sind so
kleine haltegriff sprache vom ozean der
tränen es gibt auch den ozean der zeit
in 100 jahren ist niemand mehr am leben
den wir noch kennen in einer million
jahre wahrscheinlich gar nichts mehr was
wir kennen das wasser sagt der philosoph
zu jemanden der diese doch sehr evidente
wahrheit ihnen äußert und sagt deswegen
ist das auch alles sinnlos
das wissen wir nicht wir müssen wie
gesagt den ungeheuren überblick haben
denn wenn überhaupt nur einer hat aber
kein mensch und ansonsten dürfen wir
annehmen annehmen wir wissen gar nichts
aber wir dürfen annehmen
wir sind teil der evolution wir sind
nicht aus der natur ausgefallen wir sind
teil der natur und in diesem rahmen
füllen wir eine funktion die wir
vielleicht durchschauen lernen
irgendwann aber nie vorschlägt
durchschauen
das große problem moderner menschen
besteht darin dass sie sich als
herausgefallen aus der natur wahrnehmen
oder nicht nur heraus gefallen sondern
sie sind ausgetreten aus der natur
was für ein unsinn wir sollen das
geschehen auszutreten aus der natur also
alles was geschieht auch dieses
scheinbar sinnlose geschehen ist
eingebettet in dieses große ganze um
natur arbeitet nun mal leider muss ich
sagen leider ich bin nicht einverstanden
damit
aber sie arbeitet mit unglücken das sind
mutation und die bringen unglaubliche
dinge hervor die nicht unbedingt
diejenigen schon sehen die das unglück
erleiden mussten also habe den sie nie
ganz erfassen können ist auch das
statement dieser umfassenden
sinnlosigkeit in gewissen das zum
abschluss noch eine frage an sie beide
wie würden sie denn wünschen dass man um
sie trauern
darüber habe ich überhaupt noch niemals
gedacht ich würde mir wünschen dass
menschen viele gute erfahrungen mit mehr
erinnern
und dass sie sich auch darüber erinnern
wie wir zusammen gelacht haben wo wir
auch einfach irgendetwas neues in die
welt gestellt haben vielleicht auch
etwas verrücktes also für mir für mich
trauern
natürlich werde werden sie um mich
weinen aber ich möchte eigentlich viel
lieber dass sie die erinnerung behalten
von ja das war das war schon das war
anregend
ich meine wir hatten ja auch ein paar
bücher geschrieben oder also von daher
können ja die menschen auch noch an
sie können wir sind in den büchern auch
ein stück weit da also hoffentlich
regeln wir noch ein bisschen weiter an
ist das auch eine hoffnung die sie
hätten das durch ihre bücher wie so
viele die aus dem leben gehen wünsche
ich mir nicht das um mich getrauert wird
sondern das leben voll gelebt wird mit
voller freude voller sinnlichkeit nicht
mit dem ständigen gedanken an den tod
das wünsche ich mir am meisten er steht
frau passt ich danke ihnen sehr für ihre
gedanken dass wir die zeit heute
gefunden haben für uns vielen dank der
nächste woche spricht yves bost mit dem
ökonomen gramm exten der ehemalige
generalsekretär des club of rome glaubt
dass wir den klimawandel nur überleben
wenn wir den kapitalismus abschaffen und
zwar sofort rund um unser verhältnis zur
natur gibt es auch jetzt gleich in der
sternstunde kunst der filmtitel wollten
erinnert an den amerikanischen
schriftsteller henry david thoreau
und an ein leben im einklang mit der
natur
auf einmal kommt die motorsäge zum
einsatz
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]